it is Greg Alba here and it is John yeah
no and I am from the purple army CX what
is that you would watch YouTube you
would don't I do I am you we are the
same yellow came all over my channel one
of our patreon thingies is whatever
video you request we must definitely do
whether it be a discussion or reaction
last month Rosa para one of our top
patrons requested that we do a top 10
favorite game of Thrones characters oh
boy now she just wants us to do a
reaction in a little discussion here
video called got Jon Snow the White Wolf
I wonder if this is a compilation or
something with information I don't know
but Rosa asked we shall receive
why Jane you shall receive yeah
I daresay you'll see it again next time
I see you will be all in black
there's always my cool
[Music]
you were
[Music]
[Music]
conditioner does he use
[Music]
aren't they getting married in real life
right
[Music]
all right
too much kindness people fear really
there's magic erase the beautifully
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just want to toss a movie I know right
[Music]
everything's got chills I said hard
my nipples are out then nobody cares
about your nipples
[Music]
damn Johnstone for
seriously it's really summarizes that
for us
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
yeah how far they've come
I know no he's a Targaryen I don't
forget what you are some of the
treatment
yes because John could be a successor do
we have the courage to do what's right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Wow dan is a damn well edited video put
together me yeah did he download every
single episode yeah let's do every
episode on the right moment so
dedication that was super ok cuz that
was from the first six seasons nothing a
season 7 was there so star six season
but just from sake seasons I'm like wow
this guy found so much of the right
clips to keep cutting back to intertwine
to put next to each other superb ly
edited definitely snows greatest sense
except when he's hitting Daenerys okay
there are two things about this one Kit
Harington yes
I don't feel gets enough credit for the
physical demands that you know required
to do on this show it really did show me
like excluding season seven is another
structure of the show is tends to be
like there's one episode usually second
of last that has a big battle I feel
like John Snow is usually one of the
main people in those battles he's so
heavily involved the physical demanding
part of just being this guy for so many
years remember the battle the bastard
John was catching up on season six and
he would watch it all on his iPad
whatever you want your iPad but when you
get to do episode called battle of the
bastards you better turn off the lights
put on a big TV what you do just that
one episode of it yeah
and my second thing is Jon Snow's facial
hair grows very slow yeah it does they
do not have electric razors back then it
starts off before you night's watch you
see footage there where he had zero
facial hair yeah and through the course
of time he has grown facial yeah baby
grows super slow that's what I've
learned about Jon Snow is he can't
really grow a beard and you never see
him shave why would he take the time to
do that why would he he's got other
things to do
yeah killing people making love to his
family
that's just Game of Thrones and the out
of the family Wow
you know what I hope it's then in season
eight or 7b or whatever we call it
there's one episode where like Jon Snow
like breaks an ankle and has to like
stay home while everybody else goes to
the house and Nina worries we're so
moved to tears tell me your emotional
process on so what happened during it
was but no I did keep getting goose
bumps because I just felt like the music
and the scenes that they put together
with each other
we're so powerful it was fun and I liked
watching it tickled my insides a lot I
mean sort of like so big I love it when
the music is just like yes I feel like
you know maybe Jon Snow isn't my number
one favorite character any time someone
asked me for my favorites he I tend to
list him what's your income
I feel like Brianna's problem is the
best car seriously second they should
make an all-female Ghostbusters I once
read a book that I'm terrible at flying
called 2,100 feet up along with
leadership when I think about what is in
that book how everyone is a law like the
law of navigation the law of sacrifice
the law of thing there's twenty one with
them again Jon Snow fits the mold of
every single one he is the perfect
leader interesting I love how the show
doesn't start off with him as the main
characters him as a lead but but it's at
the point where at in the show we're
like oh yeah he's our it goes yeah right
yeah yeah you have emerged as the
protagonist of this yeah I heard that
that was basically his Luke Skywalker in
the series when he was writing oh so
yeah he totally is I always think of
that whenever I see him in the in the
show I'm like yeah yeah instead of
losing this channel
Zurich to 3m hey great job on yeah
editing this video I mean it's not drugs
[Music]
you have a good handshake I'll give you
that company lost the cat years ago I
can't be the only one with a dead parrot
I'm making this a Batman situation
between us we both have the one parent
we've lost I lost grandma last year too
and you can't stop and no one's gonna
black us out do you know the darkness
that we feel inside describe to our
even after this video is done don't
don't ride because of disbelieve I will
not be on here very often so it's okay
daddy the stars on the star quick
notification bells because they
apparently do something they do know
yeah oh boy
patreon no no that this is a patron
request that we pas you guys were here
oh damn I just was not censoring a lot
of things I was very open
we love you subscribe to them yo do your
settings on your iPhone and allow
notifications I love you too